[Music]  is Lindsay Lohan ready for a musical  comeback well I'm meeting with Charlie  walk when he gets back this week so  we'll see that's what lilo told et  Wednesday night in New York City and on  Thursday we were actually with the man  she named checked Charlie walk in LA  he's a mega music producer and one of  the judges on Fox's new singing  competition the four she told us that  she wants to do mutant new music and  that you're involved she and I have been  friends for a long long time I haven't  really spoken about music recently but I  know she's reached out to talk about it  and you know once it's about always a  threat with Lindsay  you know actor singer we get together  love to hear what she's thinking do you  think it's time for a new record I think  it's really up to what she wants to do  [Music]  [Music]